[Music] That
's me, that's me too. Now,
I think I know why I came in first place. I don't tend to get very nervous on stage, so I get
a little tired of it. Wow, so I think I need to get nervous and go up.
I tend to get carried away sometimes,
but.  It
seems that Jiwoo is improving her choreography more than the lyrics are wrong.
That's because I was always confused because both microphones had
the same melody. There are
two of me, but now they are similar. Ah, there
are members who are particularly good at memorizing songs, so there are
a lot of them, so
each of them has a style that goes well with them.
No matter how much I learned,
I think I
memorized it well. Thank you [Applause] [Music] You have been very good at empathizing for over a year. I am touched. How
can you do this? You are so good at empathizing while doing this, and you are comforting the other person by making them feel good.
Ahh
[Music]
I have many members.  To me, it's
all
like that these days. It's different every time, but these days, you know the ghost's
enter without explaining it
because you found it
funny.
Ah, this is difficult. It's so different. I don't
know. For now, I'll say 3 2 1 for
1 year.
Ji-woo and the ghost are both Ji-woo and Ji-woo.  Even though he's a ghost, I
think he definitely knows something about Gyujin's style. What's he feeling these days? Is it MyToK? It's
a bit more 2K hip, but he
actually wears things differently depending on his mood.
[Music] I
chose myself for the rest. I
cry too, but I like Lily.  Somehow,
that's exactly my image. Then, did I
cry while watching the movie in front of you guys?
Anyway, I know I cried
a lot myself, but I just pictured it in front of you guys. It's so sad. I've never cried a lot in front of people, so I
thought people wouldn't single out me, but
I watched it alone.  I've seen it a lot. It's
fun.
[Music]
I woke up this morning and had breakfast. Now, I went to the shop with the
members, so
I kept sleeping in the shop. I
don't have any memories of going to the shop. When I
do Pristal Rap, I
always remember what I did today.  I talk about my daily life
like a diary. That's all
I can say. Actually, that's how I learned.
This is also difficult.
I do
n't know. Suddenly, I
don't care. She laughs whenever she gets sleepy. Suddenly, I really can't hold back laughter. I
know Hyewon knows a lot, but I
laughed every time I ran into her.  While
practicing every day,
[Music] Do we
borrow each other's clothes?
I was really pushed around a lot when I was a trainee. Oh, that's
unavoidable, so there's something about that, so in that case,
I'd call it Liliot.
But
honestly, I can't really choose this
because I got 5,000 won for myself in my dorm.  We
don't touch. Our
styles are
different. I
know why I am the way I am, but
how do I know why I am Kimchi? Me, my sister, my sister and I don't
know her, so I just do it a little. Sometimes,
when I walk, there are times when
Ji-woo is unfamiliar and
doesn't go anywhere by herself and just
follows the other girls.  There are a lot of them, so
I feel like I might not be able to
find the way when I go alone. But actually, I don't know the exact way, so I often find the way, but when I go to find it, I take
a lot of turns or keep going in circles until I get there,
so
I just
have no sense. Oh, really.  I didn't know.
When I'm doing something like pickup, I
tend to prepare the video quickly and get in the car in advance. That's right.
[Music] I
send it according to the girls' tastes.
But I experienced that yesterday. Jiwoo and
I are sitting together, and Allah keeps
uploading it at the same time.  An alarm came on my phone, and I
whined like an eraser.
But
Jang Gyu-jin,
how good is your memory? I keep thinking about how
cute I want to share with my sisters, so I'm
sending them babies these days. They
really send me a lot. My
sister is a bit of a
cave
animal, and my
sister is
a bit of a cave animal.  The funny thing is, I have a
dog, a dog, and my sister is also
a dog. This is why my sister is
sending a dog to her hometown. Oh, and
she has a lot of appetites. Is this just Harley? Is there a new product coming out? Please share something like that with me too. I
think I will like delicious food, the
two of us.  We each made a choice. That's right, I'm having a
hard time deciding between the two, but I
want it to be me, so let's
go together and do it together. I'm a
harpoon, and I've learned it all the
time during my winning streak, and I
believe in it.
I like it.
[Music]